I'm gonna land on the wing of this time
as well hey ty n you're next buddy all
right
can we're gonna do something slightly
different this week good changes good
sir change is good and you know what I
like to change I like to change the
basic world of Los Santos by adding
custom things by using the creator
beater I'll show you mine Yin you can
show me yours
her perfect standby for time for step
standby for what titanfall what's a
titanfall and you're gonna find out well
we start off next to each other and it's
just the starts off as a bit of a just
general deathmatch I'm out of I'm out of
Titan Titan keys it's just Titan B's did
you say tight yes I'll go home often
love this oh god run run you tonne fool
all right so we got these Titans alright
alright the idea is that we need to kill
each other no you can kill each other at
any mean you like we can have RPG bells
but I feel like the top of the Titan is
the best weapon and I like the idea that
what we should try and do is kill each
other by midair jousting with Titans
midair Titan yeah or you can try and
drop a ton on summers heads but
titanfall or you can shoot the other
enemies Titan out at the sky with your
RPG so the idea is you want to try and
kill the other person but then also jump
out first I'm mashing there to make sure
you get the kill I see
oh here I come I'm going for you oh I
tried to jump out you also know it's
said by place their little bikes so you
can nip quickly to the other end of the
airfield should you still wish oh I see
that that's very very thoughtful of you
yeah I know
oh gotta try this alright this is
getting interesting there you are I see
haha
standby for titanfall Seb
oh no it takes ages to jump Oh God
misty you lumbering mule ball ah geez it
faster
are you gonna get rid of a pastor the
shot I think this one might have
resolved itself quite nice a skillet
right all the bicycles gone a crash them
all did you oh you really did
why are you fast leave the target I
think we found a new fun game all right
what you got pal what you got what you
got
Oh crud that hurt uh hitting you just
nothing
oh my god my plan is the planets failed
disintegrate spikes gonna be useless to
me now today for Sarah poor Sarah no I
just yeah you I stole my plane Oh God
can I craze it quick well happy Bale
quick yes
totally totally stop ow oh come on
oh there's closest one yet love RPGs
yeah my my engine stops working yes
happening me his but hey you are bicycle
missing you well that worked out Oh God
I see no hey friends how about engine
seven have a next kill when it takes all
so I'm generous stomp guys really dumb
because you're right there all right
serve so this one this time it's a bit
different okay
only I have changed it from the last
night for this time there's only three
Titans aiming the game is to get in a
jet let's both get a jet now and then
try and crash your jet into one of the
three times I see your game the way
we're falling on the ice but this is a
there's a big butt here and that is the
fact that if you die while you do this
so if you don't manage to bail out
successfully okay then the other person
gets a point
well I'm off understand let's go Oh also
we can shoot each other damn I'm aiming
I mean it means for one I've gone out
early
I've probably got the timing all wrong
I've way overshot that oh no baby no
maybe not oh I was close Oh almost lend
you the parachutes to safety but no
tightened Dale you almost got that was
your plane
oh nice work sir oh man alright let's
try again you've actually moved one of
the Titans with your plate okay I can
see you if you look at me come see me
all right Oh God Oh God
yes there we go Oh all right so the
plane okay how'd I do
how did I do you just you may stop worst
I watched the landing damn it it wasn't
that far though right
oh this is looking really good yeah oh
here we go he giving himself enough time
yours I totally got it
I pulled my shoots one nil sip for it
one nil catch one titanfall to me I'm
gonna land on the wing of this town as
well
hey ty n you're next buddy you killed me
slow and steady wins the Titan race
went out for a bit early perhaps there
goes premature bail ulation what are the
lines that you see explode oh yes oh
it's all they've got it
I always forgot to be like oh you got it
I totally got it
epic well we tightened fell to our
deaths pretty well yeah I never really
did we make good Titan pilots hey hey
man I tightened fell three times or no
twice on Titans itaya failed well I
think we should finish with a Titan
fight oh whoa whoa whoa okay I guess
incredibly dangerous I'm holding a
rocket launcher and you just think it's
light a cigarette I'm caressing that is
that is not okay close up close up the
cigarettes
my rocket launchers in my shoulder which
I believe it's the correct stance
preacher is right you'll dance if you
look at my feet twitching pre-duel
twitch pregel groove turn now
Turner fire fire any turn in Christ of
course I sir I survived how is that even
possible
quick Titan climb don't climb Titan come
on where do I climb up this wreckage I'm
trying to all right back same again back
up there I'm on fire very uneven I'll
let you know I'm bobbing all over the
place ta all right Oh
oh god I didn't mean to do that oh yeah
I thought tighten my chin sorry that
wasn't good Titan for him was it I was
hit Titan form I wasn't there a good
tight friend no three two one tie in
fire yeah I think I'm still on the time
somehow
oh no and if I exploded you